[Music]
welcome to earbiscuits the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm Rett and I'm link this
week at the round table of dim lighting
we're still sexing it up in Timber sex
Timber episode two
Timber we have asked you what's on your
mind you want to pick our brains about
sex let us know we'll answer some of
your questions some of your voicemails
if you ever want to call us and leave us
a voicemail we know a thing or two about
sex we'll we'll listen to it how many
times you think you had sex total
yeah I I don't want to do math okay I
don't I don't want to start thinking
about you want to start keeping up with
it you know they I I'll start keeping a
log I think one of the things we're
going to talk about going to get to is
going to get to get to some of that um
like the frequency I don't know if you
ever remember being told
this I was told by several
folk right when I got married they were
like if you take a
jar and you put a penny in the jar uhhuh
for every time you have sex in your
first year of marriage and then in your
second year of marriage you start taking
a penny out of that jar every time you
have sex you'll never empty that
jar and I was like what that ain't true
that ain't going to be true for me and
that's definitely not true for me
meaning that you have sex more times
more in the first year than the second
year or for the rest of
your they said your your cup for the
rest of your marriage what was the point
of that I don't know Penny save is a
penny earned I don't know I don't know
what the point was link I think the
point was they were saying that you have
a lot of sex when you first get married
and then it tapers off very quickly and
I did not find that to be true I mean I
mean I had a lot of sex when I first got
married because we hadn't had any before
that so we like
having a lot of
sex uh I I don't remember how much sex
we had in our first year marriage I do
know in general our first year marriage
was difficult there's lots of things
you're adjusting I wasn't good at it
I'll tell you that right now but like I
mean having it I just mean just you
expand everything relationally I was
good at marriage either yeah yeah it
wasn't you know had to figure out how to
how to live with another person not only
just be with another the person sexually
right so I have to think there were
there were lots there there was a there
was a lot to
navigate and that leads to sometimes not
having sex but maybe now we could get
jars and and maybe you know what Hey
listen let's not get pennies let's do
quarters no let's do silver dollars and
then for a year we put a silver dollar
into our individual jars you know our
the family jar the mloa family and the
Neil family and then whoever
wins at the end of the year gets all the
the the the the money in the jars and
then uh we take it out we go we go on a
big
dinner and it it doesn't make sense for
us to go on a double date and then use
the all the quarters to pay
because I think the person who loses has
to pay for dinner and the person who W
won just gets to do whatever they want
to with the money well because this is
definitely in absolutely a healthy
exercise I am totally in like we are
going to turn our sexual frequency into
a competition a competition Jenna do you
want in on this
no no I don't either I I this is this is
right in line with the first tweet so
I'm going to read it from Lizette would
you rather have quickie sex every day
for the next year for less than 30
seconds that that's
lizette's uh definition of Quicky sex
less than 30 seconds that's real Quicky
good gosh I mean what is the actual
that's super quick that's not that's too
that's like gorilla gorillas have effect
real fast okay I guess cuz they got to
protect everybody it's like it's just
like a a medical injection and I believe
that gorilla's uh penis is very very
small compared to what you would think
okay I mean the pennis is really really
small on a gorilla like I mean that's
what I've heard at least I don't like it
when you say
pennis I I love it and and anytime a guy
wants to do anything just be like um but
tell me about your
penis you love it yeah yeah yeah I think
I it's slightly emasculating in a fun
way it's a technical term it's a
technical term penis penis say if it was
penis it would have two e or or another
an a ea penis it's penis uh so would you
rather have sex every day for a year and
it be a quickie every day 30 seconds I'm
going to define a quick a quickie is
like to me is insert thrust come
as fast as you can yeah but what's the
when I think of a quickie I think of
that being
ITC 13
minutes okay okay Mr big shot what are
you talking
about no dude have you ever minutes have
you ever seen a movie I'm talking like
okay I'm talking about they edit movies
hold on but what a quickie is just
like what what is the starting point in
your 13 minute that you're talking about
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm talking about
I'm not talking about th I'm talking
about like from the moment of that you
get that you get naked so there's an
alignment that has to that that how long
does that take what I'm saying is that
like you're an a library well no you're
not in a library you're in your own
personal Library I'm thinking about like
a movie you're in a library after hours
right and then well it's not 30 seconds
we agree on that you lock eyes with
someone and then the next thing you know
like you're passionately kissing and
then then all then within within 30
seconds you're naked yes it's in there
when does the time start when it when
it's in there or when the clothes come
off I'm saying or when you start making
out first of all I have to I have to
concentrate
to last a long time like it's not I mean
it feels so good yeah and so what I'm
saying is if like if if I'm if it I
wasn't saying 13 minutes of like in and
out well okay but what is the rest of it
if it what how long you thrusting in a
quickie I can get I could get it
done up against the wall in less than a
I can get it down in less than a minute
if I needed to yes I I could I know I
could I could I definitely could and
when pressed I might be listen I can go
Guerilla mode if you need me to you know
what I'm saying if we're being hunted uh
if this is the end of the world kind of
thing and I'm the one that's been it's
been put on my back to populate the
planet which it would not be possible
because I've been snipped I'm just
saying and I got to be real fast I'm on
watch you know what I mean I might be
able to get it done in less than 45
seconds I I guess where I was coming
from is I don't 13 minutes what are you
trying to prove I don't like you know
what I was really thinking was I don't I
don't think we really have quickies
where it's just for me basically well
yeah and that's I guess that's what so I
guess we don't have quickies okay okay
this isn't so sidebar conversation so my
wife and I have uh an understanding and
that understanding I would say includes
the vast majority and I would
say at least nine out of 10 maybe n
probably more realistically 19 out of 20
times that we have
sex it is she comes
first yeah and then that 5% or
less is reserved for what we would call
a quickie in
which if if she's gonna come she comes
first every single time so a quickie in
our relationship is defined by she knows
I'm just
gonna I'm just going for it yeah and I
in those cases I don't like and okay go
ahead I'm sorry well hold on no you GNA
try you try Mr 13 minutes and and you're
about to say I don't like doing that oh
come on you don't like doing that is
that what you're about to say of course
that's why 95% plus of the time because
I want her to experience The Joy of Sex
but if if she's like okay we don't have
time or I'm not I'm it's fine we're
about to go to bed and I know you really
want to have sex right now it's an
understanding she doesn't make me feel
bad about it what I'm saying is that in
those
cases because we have a convers an
ongoing conversation about
this I really enjoy it because I'm still
having sex
I'm not saying I wouldn't enjoy it but I
don't think I just I just don't prefer
it so I'm like you know I'll just
wait okay that sounds like a different
conversation yeah that's just that's
what it is it's like for me it's like I
don't know it's like I don't know it
just
feels I just I don't prefer it honestly
for me one of the things I talked about
in the last episode was
that that animalistic there's an
animalistic element to it we are animals
and this at our core sort almost defines
what humanity is you know what I'm
saying it's just like all life you know
is just propagating itself I like the
animalistic thing but what I'm saying is
that in those I that a quick like a a
totally one-sided quickie I'm just I'm
I'm saying that specifically just not
something that like I prefer but like
yeah if there's something where we're
both deferred it I'm not talking about
you at all don't be defensive I'm just
saying saying my thing but yeah but what
I'm saying is that to in in in my mind
that's like it's like a it's like a it's
again it's just like we are in the wild
we are in the jungle Anything could
happen somebody could sneak up on us at
any time we got a [__] I'm just saying
that's a special circumstance and I just
think maybe you should look into and
just enjoying it and and not if it it
doesn't need to become a regular thing
the majority of the time and obviously
only if your partner agrees but I'm just
saying that like I feel like this
conversation is set up to make it seem
like I'm being selfish because I enjoy a
very occasional quickie and I'm saying
that I don't see it that way well first
of all I'm not setting up any
conversation so get over yourself I'm
I'm just saying that that could be how
this could be
interpreted
okay so you're saying that you wouldn't
enjoy
it if I I just don't
like I mean you want to both be into it
like an a quick and like I I I haven't
had a good definition of quick I haven't
none of this you started with 13 minutes
right because I've been thinking
something totally different so what were
you
thinking that we would still that she
would still come
first okay but I think that lazette but
I and most people were probably thinking
for less than 30 seconds is a one-sided
quickie so for me maybe in this
scenario so obviously haven't even got
the other other part of the would you
rather I will just say some people do
like like I will say from a a a
perspective of someone who has has been
in that situation I don't I think
quickies can kind of be fun I'm like
look at me I'm so hot he he got done
real quick and and it was an
conversation beforehand that we didn't
have time for you know and then my needs
came later so I just saying like the I
wasn't trying to poo any I wasn't trying
to pooo with
Qui uh I I'll I just admit that I had
the wrong like a very narrow completely
one-sided yeah like having sex with a
like with a with a mannequin I guess
what I'm saying and the reason and
here's the reason I don't know why
here's the reason that's where my mind
went well here's the reason I said
haven't you seen a movie is because and
listen first of all movies are a really
bad depiction off often almost always
male Centric view of sex but what I'm
pointing out is that I don't watch a lot
of movies yeah but like when was the
last time most of the movies especially
movies we saw as kids in the 80s and
'90s it was a one-sided quickie where
the dude came in the in like 2 minutes
it's not it's not a great thing but I'm
saying that there are moments of passion
where the time that is required to go
into what I would consider the 95% you
know Mutual enjoyment going at a certain
Pace sex I'm just saying that there's a
w there's a little window in which is a
kind of a different experience and I'm
just taking a I'm not taking a stand I'm
just I'm giving a shout out to the
quickie but the question is would You'
rather have that every day for a year or
have passionate un uninterrupted Earth
shattering soulmate sex for a full 12
hours but only once a month for the next
year I would definitely well first of
all listen I'm sorry that I was thinking
the wrong thing about quickies and
implying anything about
anybody uh but my choice here is is very
much have the long thing once a month
because to me this comes down to
frequency anyway there's like a level of
like how often do you want to have sex
like where if that's your libido level
or whatever you call it you know well
clearly I think I mean my answer is is
the second part part two once a month uh
passionate sex especially if those were
these are literally the only two options
now if if it was what would I as an
individual not considering my wife enjoy
I mean a 30 second quickie every single
day to close the day down would be a
really enjoyable experience just from a
total physical release standpoint it
would it wouldn't be emotionally
fulfilling it will get kind of
mechanical but the thing is me the thing
about this question that I think lazette
is like I feel like I'm tracking with
you lazette because what you've done is
you've created two very wild extremes
right 30 second sex every single day is
a wild extreme even if I'm in gorilla
mode I don't know if I can pull it off
but at the opposite end of the extreme
a 12h hour sex session now Mr 13-minute
quickie over here may be ready to sign
up for that but I feel like I'm going to
12 hours is long I'm going to speak for
the normal folk and say that's a long
[__] time to have sex and so I think
that there is this idea that is put I'm
going to say it there's an idea that is
put into people's minds often put into
women's Minds through you know romance
novels and the like that uh if your man
is a real man then
you're going to be like when he has sex
with you it's going to last like it
might start at 700 p.m. and it's going
to go till 4:00 a.m. and he's going to
ejaculate six times and you're going to
have multiple orgasms and I'm like okay
I'll just be listen I can't do that I am
incapable of doing that even if I would
even if I would like to do that uh by
the by the fourth time I would just be
ejaculating dust do you know what I'm
saying so I don't believe that I would
be capable of doing that and so I just
feel like that that extreme now if
you're talking about it says soulmate
sex for a full 12 sex for a full 12
hours that's impossible you might be
able to have a sexual encounter that
stretches over a half a day where you
never put your clothes back on well
you're definitely making it sound like
torture but 12 hours is too long yeah I
so what's the I so I guess what's the
ideal cuz we both agree if we had to we
had to choose we're going to do the one
where our wife gets to come once a month
of of course that's what I'm going to
choose but what's the ideal length
length Neil the ideal
length um like if you're designing the
night I think there's two different and
foreplay is not included in this time
scan I foreplay is important and
foreplay is necessary but foreplay could
literally be a text that you do in the
morning where it's just like I can't
wait for tonight no I'm saying once you
start the session once the section SE
start but but foreplay is part can be
part of that I'm saying in this
scenario this is I'm saying that this is
one once you're in the bedroom the door
is locked the music has started and
there's sexual physical things that are
beginning to happen which can
be the foreplay right the actual and I'm
saying in the bedroom foreplay and I'm
saying in this and I'm talking about
this is a normal encounter in which in
my typical encounter there is one
ejaculation from me yes uh absolutely
okay my refractory period uh has
increased as I've gotten older uh so
twice in a day I have done it I do do it
the second time can be hard to pull off
sometimes I haven't tried that in in
quite a while but like uh I think I
would need to there would need to be
like some sort of
uh I got to really gear up for that I
think there might need to be a bribe
involved right yeah like a like a
suitcase full of money so what's the
ideal time from from your perspective
taking into account sort of the your the
preferences of your partner from
beginning of sexual activity to your
ejaculation which of course is after her
orgasm
uh um we're starting with a 13-minute B
Bas Quicky Baseline so I'm expecting a
very high number no no no it's like it's
like 15
minutes I've already said that like I
didn't I wasn't I my answer wasn't for a
a a quickie I didn't know what a quickie
was okay that's
interesting
damn
um it depends on which mode I'm in like
in just a normal it's a week night ideal
mode but not like romantic getaway like
we were talking about last week okay
normal life normal normal life mode
ideal amount of time in my mind
is uh 29 minutes
okay and I was or less I was hoping you
were going to say less than 30 minutes
because you were going to make me feel
bad well clearly I've been doing that
the whole time now here's the thing I
want to be better at this I want to be
more
patient um I want to stretch things out
well that's probably a bad do you want
to you're saying want you stretch the
timeout she
um um no we talk we we talk
about like this first of all
Jesse and I have a very satisfactory sex
life and we're very happy but if we were
to sit down and I were to say these are
the things that I want more of from you
and she were to say these are the things
I want more of from
you one of the things on her list would
be I want you to go slower and take your
time more
often um and
so cuz for me
like I you know one I think I talked
about this in one of the previous sex
timers but you know I I've made it clear
that I'm a I'm a I'm a fan of the Cy
Lingus uh that is a normal part of our
process and I I mean sometimes I just
want to start right there and I know
that's too much that's too I mean it's
too much for her sometimes you know what
I'm saying it's like there should we I
should kiss other things first and uh
and I recognize that um like her mouth
yeah yeah like I should kiss her mouth
first sometimes
wow and uh and I do I do I do that okay
uh but so I would say that my ideal time
taking into account what I know that she
wants and what I know that I want and
I'm kind of using like music to is
that's one way to know how long things
have been going like how many songs have
played yeah and I have noticed that
there's sometimes where it's like oh
[__] we're only on the second song it's
over you know what I'm saying like I
think this I think this is I think this
was a seven minute encounter yeah um cuz
sometimes things can happen very quickly
for her as
well um depending on a number of factors
but I would say that typical I would say
typical is probably 20 minutes and I
would say ideal I I was going to say
half an hour so I think we're on the
same page until in what we actually want
it to be but then there's also I think
she would Jesse would want it to be more
she would be pushing she would be
pushing for 45 minutes yeah we're more I
mean
we're more on the same page it's like is
both if we both get the experience we
want I mean it's more it we're kind of
results oriented more than process
oriented I think and so we're pretty
much and we're like you know we don't
like to compromise our bedtime you know
yeah really you know some sometimes I'll
brag about uh getting it done and then
it's like look it's it's it's not even
9:30 yet yeah like I I have
legitimately celebrated that yeah that
that's a big factor that's a big factor
it's like every like we've checked all
the boxes and including the last big box
which uh is the juiciest box of all and
that box is keeping my bedtime h i you
know so we we've literally celebrated
that you were making a box joke though
in I was okay and um so I think we're
more on the same page on that front the
other part of it is
frequency you know and I think that that
this question kind of brings up part of
that too you know so it's like like
being on the same page about these
things I think that uh you know there's
it it's I can it kind of goes in waves
right for me sometimes and I correlate
it to like you know just energy level
stress level I sometimes I could go
weeks and be like you know what I just
I don't I don't have any drive I have
noticed that it's cyclical and we go in
and out of it so like we we we ride the
waves but
um so it's actually hard to say what a
frequency is you know on a monthly B I
would say more on a a monthly number
versus a weekly number in terms of like
what my what my desire is but it's
probably um
two and I'm trying to be really re
realistic here two times
like one
point if it's one point I think if it's
1.7 times a week what's that times four
four five that's all like seven times a
month maybe
yeah um I I agree about it coming In
Waves um
it can be dependent on how busy you are
how stressed out one or both of you
are um do you find yourself first of all
going like what I said like you like
there's a stretch of time when you just
you don't have um much
drive I would say it's funny because I
would say that to me there is a and I
remember I remember somebody telling us
this right when we were about to get
married um Mark told us this he was like
sometimes it can it can kind of
sometimes it's hard to you're not going
to understand this until you get married
but sometimes it can feel like working
out sometimes it can feel like something
you you know you have to do you know
you'll feel good afterward or in this
case during it's a loose analogy but the
choice to begin to do it might be mind
over matter and uh the thing that
because the vast and and actually this
is a conversation that Jesse had I I've
had and I think actually led to this
like acceptance of this uh infrequent
frequency of the quickie thing because I
would tell her I was like to be honest
with you I kind of always want to have
sex I mean there there's I I I kind of
always want to have sex and then maybe
this sheds light on on that Quicky
conversation earlier but yeah
like 75% of my waking hours and I don't
know about my sleeping time but I assume
I have you know is with an erection wet
dreams and
things 75% of your Waking Life you have
a heart on no no no not anymore I'm not
14 uh 75% of my Waking
Life I'm ready to go you know what I
mean and and I but I but that doesn't
translate into having sex every single
day uh because I want the vast majority
of our encounters to be something that
is enjoyable to her and she wants a
certain pace and she wants me to perform
in a certain way and right and be and be
there for it and be there for the
sensual uh equal experience and
sometimes I'm just like I want to have
sex but I don't necessarily
want to sign up for this half hour
encounter right now because I kind of
just want to read this book and go to
bed but yeah I do want to have sex but
I'm not going to ask for it
because I don't want it to be a quick
because I don't want that frequency to
get above whatever 5% but you're still
so but I'm saying I still want to do it
uh but that doesn't mean it it
translates into the super high
frequency right I don't know what frequ
is but I'm talking about like desire on
your part CU I'm saying the desire to
have sex is is on one level and then the
the desire to actually begin the process
of having sex is like requires a next
level of intention does that make sense
yes definitely and there's you know I've
heard of people saying of
course people have all different types
of sex drives and you know if you're in
a relationship with somebody it's like
you there's there's going to most likely
there's going to be some level of
misalignment you're not going to be in
like lock step with each other so there
is you know it's cool to hear that like
you talk about it and like and you meet
each other's needs and stuff like that
um and it it kind of helps with like the
the quickie thing because without
talking about it I mean my sort of
experience with other um with other
couples and this things I I hear and
pick up on you
know is that it is not uncommon at all
for for Mary couples or just you know
couples who are been who live together
and have been together for a
while uh for like it's kind of easy for
these barriers to just get locked in
place and it can be very very difficult
for them to get dislodged right and so
then you can find yourself going weeks
going months going [__] years yeah
without having sex because not because
you don't want to but because now it's
gotten awkward you know um and so I
thankfully I haven't had to to deal with
that I'm sure there are some couples who
are like that's just who we are and
we're happy and whatever it may not be
they even desire that but I would say
that if there's one or both people in
the partners that want to be having more
sex and there's there is that
misalignment just it's all about having
a conversation about you like oh you've
been that's what you've been thinking
you haven't been approaching me because
you've been expecting me to do this or
you never know what'll happen to you
just it's much easier to begin the
conversation than it is to re-engage
sexually sometimes yeah I've also heard
about this thing called [__] You Ary
like let's have sex every day of the
month of February or pick any month or
any period of time
and I thought fober you know we we
talked about doing that but that was
just like I mean if I'm saying you know
less than two times a week is is is fine
by me it's like that's just kind of
forcing an issue it it sounded like an
interesting experiment in my head but
then it just like I said I would be
afraid it would become too mechanical
but then but the thing is is I think it
wouldn't I I think that's the
I don't know what well that kind of gets
into this other question which is you
know uh poopy rocket man asks how goofy
is Goofy missionary which goofy
missionary I believe is just a term
coined by
Trevor during the smos roast when he
invented the rumor that all I liked was
missionary
sex uh which I listen did he say goofy
missionary I think so yeah yeah yeah so
uh I don't think missionary is Goofy at
all I think it is a great sexual
position it is not my favorite sexual
position okay uh but I would say it is
potentially the most frequent sexual
position um there's Alternatives there's
you can mix up you can make missionary
goofy which maybe is what Trevor was
getting at because if you're just
picturing like a k doll and a Barbie
doll like flat on top of each other and
somehow the the penis is being inserted
into the vagina that's not what
missionary Jenna face said that's not
what uh missionary is as far as I'm
concerned there's there's there's ways
to make that more interesting you can
you can put yourself up I think that
maybe that's called something different
on on your hands and the legs can go
straight up in the air the you know your
partner can be folded into the shape of
an L you know there's there's lots of
things that happen in that orientation
that I have explored thoroughly yeah I
like a little origami little human
origami uh so I'm basically I think what
I'm saying is that it can get kind of
goofy and I was a missionary for a while
so I Really Deserve You are goofy to own
that but it lets you be more inventive
that's what having sex every single day
would do it would point out the places
where you've gotten to paint by numbers
which is something that I'm sensitive to
and Jesse is definitely sensitive to you
know she wants it to be you know e even
though we have a pretty uh like like I
said it's very consistent like she's
going to have her time I'm going to have
my time we're going to have our time
people are going to feel fulfilled and
they're going to get what they came
for but if it kind of follows these few
steps every single
time it can be like all right let's
let's change it up and I so having sex
every single day I think would force you
to figure that out um when ever there's
there's many times that when we're in
the act and then I'll say what you know
we'll both say cuz like
we we're both in that place where it's
like we're you know her her she's not
like I want to have sex more she's not
there so like we're closer in terms of
our drive we hear about people who like
do it every day and we're like damn I
feel like I should feel bad but like hey
there's you know I don't we don't need
to compare ourselves but then I do I I
like the idea of having sex and boy
whenever we're doing it like I've said
out loud many times why don't we do this
more often yeah it's like why did we
wait so long since last time we did this
like when you go to the beach it's like
God this is wonderful we're so close
don't you agree why don't we just go
here more often and I'm like and like
I'm just like you know it's just like
when I'm on vacation I'm planning the
next vacation I do that with sex we're
having sex and I'm
like let's make sure we do this again
tomorrow I've literally said that it's
like again tomorrow typically on
vacation the
everyday oh yeah it's not it's not the
it's not the Benchmark necessarily but
I'm not talking about being I'm talking
about normal at home no I I've said many
times like and sometimes I've been
like before we finish let's agree let's
agree that we're going to do this again
tomorrow and then I mean everybody we're
all in agreement at that moment the
thing is is that you do that for like
everything that you enjoy you're you if
you're enjoying something you're asking
anyone who's there to agree to do it
again which I really appreciate that I
do feel like I benefit from that but it
does feel a little bit uh like a like an
attorney yeah like can we agree it's
right now to do this again tomorrow yeah
it's not the most passionate exchange
let's do this again
um yeah I uh
the then I get a sip of water or a
guzzle of water there's plenty of things
I do during
sex I think that drink water negotiate
the next time we're going to have sex
the Bedtime thing is a big factor and I
actually think that I am more of a hey I
want to get I'm not a 930 man I don't
know how the hell you do that I wish I
knew how you did that uh I'm a I'm a
10:30 is my target okay 11 11:30 is my
my reality and um now Jesse and I've
told I've told her this a million times
I was
like anytime anytime with almost no
exception if I decide that I for
whatever reason I'm staying up later
because I'm working on something or I'm
reading something or I'm watching
something when one any of the many
reasons that I may not go to bed on time
she'll always still be up She'll always
still be up it's like the woman doesn't
need sleep it's like it's almost like
she might be an alien who doesn't
require sleep but is reminded oh I need
to act like I have to sleep because I'm
playing a human and my human yeah my
human that I live with is now sleeping
so now I must
sleep I don't know how she does it she
seems to function very highly with the
amount of sleep that she gets um so that
I think that that can be some sometimes
sometimes it'll be like she'll want to
begin the engagement and I'm like ah I
was literally just about to roll over
and go to bed which I think is a little
bit of a roll reversal from what people
The Stereotype is right um but I think
that having one kid out of the house and
just having one
left
who I mean Shephard you know he's 15
he's half the time when I'm going to bed
I don't know where he's at without like
looking at my like finding him on my
location finder or whatever you know but
I think that that has increased our
frequency because it can be like oh it's
8:00 and we're the only two people in
this house oh yeah I'm not at that point
and so I think that that so I'm actually
anticipating that in four years when
he's gone and we're empty nesters I
actually think that our frequency will
take
another another boo it'll be like we're
on vac we'll be on vacation all the time
I'm I'm sure we'll find out that we're
wrong about that but I'm really hopeful
too I'm feeling feeling that hey uh we
forgot to promote the golden tea
mythicality we need to do that yes we're
doing the golden tea of
mythicality uh it's officially here now
through September
29th um all you got to do is go to
mythical.com secure your very own shiny
tea and now remember this works the same
way that it works every year but we've
got new prizes this year so everybody
gets this shiny tea but three people get
a special different color shiny tea so
the golden tea you get that gold te you
get $24,000 in cash because it's season
24 Good Mythical warning that's crazy if
you get the orange tea you get a virtual
taste test with us where we sit down
hang we send you some food we have the
same food we both eat it we talk we hang
out we chill for a while if you get the
blue tea you get $2,400 in uh credit at
the mythical store where you can go and
probably buy everything that we're
selling at least um so again go to
mythical.com to enter the 2023 golden
tea of mythicality giveaway for a chance
to win one of those incredible prizes no
purchase necessary void where prohibited
visit mythical.com for details yeah uh
also we want to make sure we've been
trying to remember to ask you to do this
but we keep forgetting uh listen if you
like your biscuits uh first of all thank
you for liking it thank you for
listening the main thing you can do is
just continue listening continue telling
people about it but something that is
very helpful is rating and reviewing on
Apple or Spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcast you know it does things
to the algorithm it gets the podcast to
be shown to more people so we can bring
more ear biscuits along for the please
review this
podcast as a favor to us more people can
hear us talk about
sex ear biscuit is supported by Rosetta
Stone you know I really wish that I
would have learned Spanish like why do
we take all the French courses like like
I don't have the opportunity to speak
French to that many people I have one
French friend but I have a lot more
friends who speak Spanish and like have
a lot of opportunity here in Southern
Cali to speak Spanish we were not well
advised we were not well advised it
wasn't practical cue the promo for
Rosetta Stone Rosetta Stone is the most
trusted language learning program and it
truly immerses you in the language you
want to learn they've used trusted
experts for 30 years with millions of
users and 25 Lang languages offered
including but not limited to Spanish and
French but also Italian German Korean
Chinese Dutch and Arabic and more and
it's built for fast language acquisition
Ros out of stone immerses you in many
ways by having an intuitive process so
you pick up a language naturally first
with words then phrases then sentences
and it's designed for long-term
retention the coolest feature to me is
the built-in true accent feature it
gives you feedback on your pronunciation
so you can can learn to speak like a pro
like a giggled at plus it's super
convenient as it has a desktop and app
option with audio companion and ability
to download lessons offline a lifetime
membership has all 25 languages for any
and all trips and language needs in your
life it's a $299 program but when you
use our code you can get it for just
$179 don't put off learning that
language there's no better time than
right now to get started for a very
limited time you can get r Stone's
lifetime membership for 40% off that's
$179 for unlimited access to 25 language
courses for the rest of your life redeem
your 40% off at rosettastone.com
today let's let's click on a uh a
voicemail hey red link it's September
and so I wanted to suggest a topic or
actually ask you all a question so why
is it that in the year of Our Lord 2023
or whatever Lord you believe in that
adult toy shops or sex shops still feel
so skevy and like they're trapped in the
80s they always smell weird the displays
always feel like a blast from the past
in a bad way the DVDs look like they
were made in the 1980s still everything
about them just makes you feel terrible
walking in them so why are they still
like that are the stores like that and
LA and yeah so yall could explore that
that' be
great you remember that store we went
into I can't believe they still exist at
all because of the internet well but
yeah but you can't touch a dildo on the
internet no you know what I mean so I
think the a lot you can't return them I
guess I think a lot of this stuff you
need to you need to see in person oh you
can't return them at stores either just
so you just so you know right I mean
listen but you can look at them before
you buy them true and a lot of people
are not great kind pick it up a lot of
people are not great with numbers so
somebody like I'm going to get an 8 in
dildo and then they're like oh okay or a
13-minute I wasn't expecting it to be
that big uh so I think that um that's
that's that's the reason they exist
because it's the same reason that like
clothing stores still exist because
sometimes you need to try I mean you
don't try it on I guess but you know
what I'm saying you need to get into the
same room with it I haven't been to one
recently you remember the one that we
went to we probably told the story at
some time um the first time the first
time we went into an adult store in
Charleston we went into an adult store
more recently maybe while traveling
while touring or something and it felt
like the Apple Store of um sex stores
you remember that place I I was in there
yeah you were in there you went in there
with me I just remember thinking this
feels like an Urban Outfitters or
something it was apparently there are
those and I assume that those exist in
LA but I do I am good with numbers so um
when you tell me how long something is I
can picture it okay uh so I do most of
my toy ordering online yeah I I do my
ordering online because it yeah cuz even
if I have not
found and I don't remember that shop and
I have not surely there's like a really
awesome like there's got to be but like
like high-end sex shop in LA do you guys
know about any Wheezy uh Pleasure Chest
is a pretty good one it's pretty it's
pretty open that's in
Hollywood um there's also actually they
opened one in North Hollywood as well so
if you're in the Val but does it still
have the does it still have the skey
Vibes because I didn't I don't think so
I think those on it's open it's like
brightly colored uh there are you're
going to find the skevy ones around the
ones that have most of like the lingerie
in the front there's one in Pasadena
right on Colorado which is like such a
quaint little and even that one like the
mannequins with
the really like the barrier to entry is
High Extreme long the kind of stuff like
if you got young kids you kind of like
don't want them to look into the window
kind of vibe yeah like it just feels
like it wouldn't be hard to take a
slight left turn and all of a sudden
your business would just go through the
roof cuz the people who just want like a
ball pit for the kids the people who who
want the what are those balls made out
of people who who want the the most
extreme stuff well that's still inside
it's in the back man you know yeah but
like you don't have to feel weird at all
about just walking in this place it just
feels like more sex shots should be
taking that yeah I just I just think the
margins aren't high enough and they
already exist and they can't afford to
like revamp their whole
thing okay I think it's this is just an
economics answer unfortunately but of
things that you can sell at a sex shop
what could you put in the window that
would make it I mean
come to think of it like first of all
you're like come to think of it which by
the way that's a great name for a sex
shop come to think of
it that's good yeah you know think to
come of it yeah yeah we'll Workshop it
but of the things that you could put in
the window you're you start with
mannequins because that's just what you
do and what the they're tall Windows it
seems like what you should do and then
you're like well let's right because
you're not going to put the dildos in
the window can't put the dildos in the
window and if you're just putting Lubes
in a window it's just like what so toys
and stuff don't make sense I understand
where they're going I just think you
don't have Windows well know but then
how do people know how do people know
it's a sex shop I think they could do a
display with the mannequins and then
like the lingerie and like feather boas
and then there's like subtle things like
a little feather duster little
crop something subtle where you're like
taste I know what that is yeah this is
not Victor secret this is Victoria's
Open
Secret yeah I haven't I haven't I would
love to fix their display windows I
would I volunteer if anyone wants to
display window
fix let's go to another one cuz I don't
you know come to think of it it ain't
getting better than
that hey R link huge fans first time
caller um so I just turned 40 years old
um been married for 15 years and um real
simple question delicate situation I
guess I don't know um so I like to uh
keep my pubes nice and trimmed my wife
appreciates it you know she's willing to
uh visit the garden if the weeds are
taken care of you know what I mean yep
and uh so I like to keep those nice and
trim but I also like to uh fully shave
my balls I think it looks good feels
good um but like I said I just turned 40
so how old is too old to keep uh
manscaping I guess at what age do you
finally just uh Let It Go um so just
question for you guys looking for some
answers and appreciate all you guys do
thanks first of all buddy you don't
don't stop never it's that's like saying
it's addictive I'll tell you you've been
pulling the weeds all these years and
then the next thing you know like this
year you're not pulling the weeds you're
going to you ever seen one of those old
professors
eyebrows right you know what I'm saying
like that's what's going to happen
you don't know how coily that stuff's
going to be it might poke her eye out
when she's down there in the garden you
might you might lose your wiener
entirely it might wrap around it and
suffocate it yeah you you don't you
don't you don't want that to happen do
you um now I will say I don't um I don't
keep a you know how like some people's
Lawns are all like if you show up at a
certain person's house their lawn always
looks exactly the same and then there's
other people that you know that like
sometimes you show up at a party and
you're like damn y'all's lawn looks
great and then like you show up around
Christmas and you're like y'all need to
cut the grass yeah I'm sort of the
second scenario mostly because I just
feel like it's a little Dynamic
sometimes I look like somebody who may
have come from a different era you know
what I mean okay and sometimes I look
like somebody from the future sometimes
you're Grizzly Adams sometimes the past
and sometimes I'm from the future and
sometimes I'm right now ready to go
what do you do I I talked about this on
Good Mythical evening you know in the
aftermath of them ripping off the
plaster mold of my ass cheeks which was
all your fault by the way um and all the
hair that they ripped off you know what
happened was I came I I was strutting
around and Christy noticed that like
you're walking a little
faster wind was she was like your cheeks
are so smooth what happened and I told
her
and then I was like oh because she
noticed well clearly that's an up
obviously you
know I I I it's not that I I I just
hadn't thought that she noticed so then
I was like [__] because she
notices I'm going to I'm going to get
those manscape Clippers yeah not a
sponsor should be though cuz I've got
them and I've used them for years boy
I'm a fan come on let's have a
conversation manscape I manscaped with a
D manscaped uh past tense I love what
you're doing to me cuz uh you said that
you had that and you had everything had
been like trimmed all the way
down and um so then I got one and then I
started to trim it on trim it all the
way down by the time Good Mythical
evening happened it was like I was just
getting used to it and I I'm pretty good
at keeping
everything down down all the way it like
it trims really close now this this guy
talking about shaving his balls with
like a razor he's I think I don't think
he's I don't I mean if he's doing that I
hope you're
using talking about what we're talking
about yeah like Clippers like but like
without a level but you got to get ones
that aren't going to Nicky Nicky Nicky
what about you said all the way down the
pubic region what are you talk what do
you when you say all the way down what
everything
everywhere you're
bald yes okay and
and I'm enjoying it so this is the thing
every not it is not uncommon that once I
start I think every time I start like if
I'm if it's a little overgrown you know
we're talking about like I've been on
vacation and I forgot to pay the boy to
cut the
grass the boy yes you know you pay some
boy to cut the grass and a
kid uh just to be clear there is no boy
involved in this process I wanted to
analogy about grass cutting okay
neighborhood grass cutting well you
don't want to forget right before
vacation that is the worst time to
forget my friend uh yeah okay bad
analogy sorry when I haven't cut it in
cut it when I haven't trimmed it in a
while and I break out those manscape
Clippers which boy they're wonderful
wish they were a sponsor
um I always think that I'm going to do
something
like okay I want to still have have some
presence above it you know
MH but I want it to be like
trim flattering whatever yeah yeah yeah
that can work but I always end up going
all the way yeah it's you just some once
you because it's just like shaving your
sideburns you know in high school we had
sideburns and you try to keep it even
next thing you know you're like
G from Street Fighter like just go
straight across the middle of balls look
like G
uh and I got to say I enjoy it but
then it feels really like um you feel
smooth and quick and and you feel like a
sexual energy I think yes there's an
energy to it but then it kind but then
it slowly grows back and so I gota I
gotta feel I feel like I need I need a
happy
medium I will say the thing about the
butt hair though you can also what about
it so
I
trimmed my butt hair and I didn't have a
whole lot but of course I'm like any man
I've got crack hair great not a lot of
cheek hair but I knew that that mold
that chase was going to be painting on
my ass was going to go into the crack so
I CH I I trimmed everything mhm and uh I
wear you know a box or brief me too like
a meundies or whatever
Y and what I noticed is
that I didn't have a lot of hair in my
ass but I had enough hair to keep my
underwear from going on my ass
crack that that doesn't happen to me but
it does I have felt a little a little
it's a little it can get a little more
sticky right I was just like hold on
what's Happening I feel like I'm having
to pick my underwear like during the
middle of the day so I kind of feel like
I need a little barrier just a little
bit yeah I'm it doesn't take
much right you know I'm I'm still I'm
still on team going all the way but it
does take an adjustment there's an
adjustment period maybe I got to get a
different kind of underwear to figuring
it out now there's this other thing
called A N I think it's called a n we
have this too it's like oh it's like a
Roomba you just put it it's a robot that
you put on your balls and it just runs
around by itself it flashes this light
and it kills your hair folicles if you
use it enough I'm not doing that and
they say you can use it anyway I just
haven't had my balls aren't even even
like I don't I'm I got a vasectomy and
I'm still I can't bring myself to like
light shock my actual balls I don't
think I don't I wouldn't mess with that
bro but oh I've been using it I've been
using it in other places I've been using
it on my butt cheeks is this like the
electrolysis thing your grandma had in
in that that room in her house no no no
that was a you would stick a needle down
into each follic yes so in that way yes
so yeah it is the same it kills the
follicle but it sends current down the
hair it's no current it is a it's a it's
a handheld device that you just you put
on your skin over where the you want the
hair to not grow anymore and then it it
it's like a flash of a
camera and it's kind of It kind of
stings a little bit there's seven levels
to it and I've been using that what's it
called I think it's called a nude n nud
n o o d not n yeah the N is like a
weight loss thing so
nood I've been using this thing how'd
you know about this um Christy of all
they sell all kinds of stuff they sell
this they sell a bra for women that's
just pasties that that that's uh that's
booby tape man well hold on but yeah but
it sort of caught me off guard that's
great that's the same thing where's
the the machine I saw the machine oh try
nude oh hold oh there's a l nude.com and
a try nude well there's a lawsuit going
here yeah this is
ity there's two people trying to do nude
things the Flasher 2.0 that's what I
have somebody didn't get a trademark I
I'm using it on my ass cheeks I'm using
it on the top of my feet because I don't
like hair on my toes and the top of my
feet I got this i got this place where
look you can see it right there I've got
hair that grows on my wrist on the
inside of my wrist and I don't like it
so this one place right here I zap and
you can tell right now that it's like
there's a little bit of it's not what if
you want your hair back what if it comes
in fashion too late I'm not yeah I can't
hairy astrend well yeah I'm I'm at risk
of not being on that train I would do it
on my napes my I've started doing it on
my napes because I'm ad I get addicted
to all this stuff once I start removing
hair you know when I started trimming my
I started trimming my leg hair and like
nobody understands that but like I don't
know I feel like makes me feel happy and
it makes it me feel like are you you're
not going any lower are you no okay good
I'm actually triming my leg hair less
now that
everything under the underwear is
totally gone and I'm permanently
removing the hair off of my feet where
did you hear about this boy Life
Magazine Christy bought one and then I
just saw it and she never opened it oh
she got one and she didn't use it she
got it and hasn't used it I was like
well I'm going to use this I'm going to
show you that you you need to use it and
you're you you can use it on like your
bikini line and stuff like that that's
what is happening I've seen ads for guys
talking about removing the hair off
their balls with this thing and I'm
going to get
there um I don't know that okay I want
to do that to my my bush though no dude
you don't know what's going to happen
right yeah you need to have a you have
you got to have the ability to have a
bush you never know what's gonna happen
but I think I'm gonna manscape forever
yeah back to the question at hand do not
stop do not stop it's fun it's great
it's um it's exciting makes makes you
feel like a
pornographic you know star yeah uh Ben
Barker he uh well I will say that his
Twitter his Twitter handle is DB
longdong okay um so
uh didn't see that probably means it's
not that long yeah
how has getting your tubes snipped
affected your libido and performance if
any well I guess they are tubes so it
doesn't have any any effect on either of
those things um you it's had the biggest
effect we I mean I used condoms before I
got VC yeah our wives neither of our
wives were ever on birth control
interestingly long story
um and so we were we did we were condoms
and so I would say that yeah if I talk
about Freedom I'd say it it
upped it didn't Up Performance to begin
with no for obvious reasons right no um
in fact up sensation what I will say I
don't do you ever do this uh okay so
there there are times use a fruit rollup
as a conom yeah no no there are still
times and I would this is very
infrequent but it happens maybe a few
times a year
where for whatever reason uh Jesse don't
want to get so messy if you know what I
mean and uh so I have a bag of condoms
really yep I have a bag of condoms for
this purpose well to I mean again if
it's that Quicky and she's doing it just
for you maybe that is a that's a perfect
example is that a hand in hand uh I
don't do it in the hand
okay um so yeah God doesn't like that
okay I never spill my seat because of
laan what was his name in I think hey a
dude spilled his seed in the Bible and
he got struck down
y'all you got to watch
that um I uh I have these condoms and
sometimes I'll be like you know just
literally as a jizz catcher yeah yeah
but it makes you it makes it easier to
last longer because there's a barrier
there yeah cuz it does it does impact
the um the sensation a little bit I mean
have you ever tried some of that um like
you use
that
desensitizing I've never I haven't yeah
I have and uh I just that ain't for me
man it it goes too too
desensitized uh yeah I can't feel my
dick at all you got to kind like first
of all there's just something about like
stopping and applying some I don't know
what it is it's just but like yeah I
think I think I maybe tried it twice
just to see what would
happen
um but it was like one time it was too
much too much and was just like this is
like I I'm not enjoying this anymore
yeah um I I haven't tried
it but well if you don't have a need to
try it but
the but you use a condom sometimes you
have a b bag of condoms
I think every man needs a bag of condoms
I mean just for that huh yeah uh and
then sometimes if we're if if we're uh
you know if we are in the window so to
speak uhhuh yeah um she's on her
period uh that is a good time for
that um that's a good point and um huh
yeah but I would
say if you need help with that so hasn't
it hasn't impacted performance but I
would say that once you begin
having this you know unshed
sex boy it is it's Superior at that
point I think that you can well careful
now it's I mean men need need to be
wearing condoms okay yeah we're we're in
a long-term monogamous relationship
ejaculate responsibly boys but I will
say men please go get vasectomies for
the most part they are are reversible so
if you are concerned why not just get a
vasectomy yeah there you go I don't how
reversible very for like pretty like
this the percentage is high for
reversibility you got to fish you got to
fish out the all right I'll fish out
both ends of the tubes I want I want all
all the men to get vasectomies and then
when they feel financially and
emotionally responsible then they can
get
yeah but but what I found is that the
you once you have the
unshed sex on a regular basis you can
actually kind of focus on like becoming
a better performer again that like for
me with my tendency to want to rush
things it's like that that has that has
have to it's a it's a very it's a mental
thing where I really have to
commit um yeah you got to make the
decision you got you got to switch
things up I think we talked about that
last year yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the key all success rate is 60 to
95% depending on how many years you have
had the
vasectomy okay okay all
right in in my
monogamous no longer wanting kids
situation it was it was a
no-brainer you know especially when I
realized we could make a video about it
and it would be
funny well and it's such a it's such a
low um especially in the situation that
we're in where it's just like there's no
we don't want to ever reverse it
um it's such a small sacrifice for the
man when the woman has has been carrying
like
99 100% of the burden related to
reproduction right right uh so it's very
easy to be like well I'm just going to
do this thing that hurt me for a weekend
I put some peas on my ball sack and I
was and watch some movies and I was okay
it was no big deal and but you've got
you know the birth control measures for
women are much more
uh uh impactful and burdensome right so
you're talking about like IED or what is
it it's a IUD IUD even even the pill you
know like the reason that Jesse didn't
use it well reason we didn't use it
originally is because we were super
super conservative Evangelical
Christians and we thought that the pill
could prevent implantation and cause an
abortion and so even the very very small
chance of a fertilized egg not being
implanted we would see that as abortion
and so we were against it at the time
changed my view on that since but then
uh Jesse realized that she has a
propensity to blood clotting uh uh which
you know it can contribute to that so
it's just these measures can be really
burdensome for women so I mean at least
you know these dudes here are like I'm
not going to wear a condom cuz it
doesn't feel good it's like that home
mentality is just so [__] up and then
the yeah and then not being willing to
get a vasectomy because you don't
understand what is actually happening
which that tends to be the case that I
you still have a full load yeah uh well
it's not full of sperm it's a spermless
but it seems Seems no different it looks
exactly the same it feels exactly the
same because your sperm is a minuscule
percentage of your semen load it didn't
change that part of the experience at
all I noticed no difference in an orgasm
or the jizz or I notic no
difference yeah here's a
voicemail hi R link my name is amberlin
and I have a question for your upcoming
sextember podcast I was wondering if you
could give us the most laqua and
adjective field description of the male
orgasm that you can thank you very much
love you guys godbye I wish I wish I had
KN known that was what was going to be
asked the most loquacious um description
of the orgasm I feel like and I mean
it's like it's it's you know it's like
Colonel Sanders with his with his
pressure cooker you you know you got the
chicken bone in the in that thing and
boy it's getting hot and boy
sh sh the the way that the it's just
like the pressure just builds up to the
point where it's just like Sanders back
up because Colonel sander Lids about to
pop off and it's just you know it could
blow you back blow you back and it can
get
greasy I think that's what is pretty
good I mean you missing the best finger
looking
good yeah yeah man you missed the
slogan it's finger looking good you
missed the slogan it's finger looking
good uh I'll 11 finger looking good I'll
give you a
uh I'll give you a loquacious
description of um the first time I ever
U orgasmed by my own
hand it was like a I mean this is
exactly the way I thought about it the
next day it was like an itch that I
could not stop scratching that felt so
good and only felt better and better and
better the more I scratched yeah until
the point that it felt
like the whole of the universe had
descended onto my groin yeah and needed
to like it's like a star was being
born you know what I'm saying it was
like what I don't know how Stars
happen uh but you know what how it feels
for it to happen thinking about a black
hole at the time and I know they're
related somehow and I I just remember
first of all I remember thinking that I
had broken my dick um because I did not
I had not been well
educated uh about this but yeah that's
how I thought about it was just like a
uh and I often wonder like how does it
you
know because they say they
say that if uh if you've got a
clitoris that uh just the the number of
nerve endings and stuff and the way it's
oriented or whatever I just remember
somebody like like I heard like a doctor
on Oprah say when I was a kid like a
woman enjoys orgasm five times as much
as a man and I was like okay I don't
know how you know that but if that's
true if a woman enjoys it more than I
enjoy it it's like good for y'all well
the thing thing is a female orgasm I am
jealous I'm jealous because it
like it lasts it lasts there's like
there's like a plateau and it's like the
difference between like a Rocky Mountain
and like a like a whole Plateau you
could and depending on all the factors
you can you could build a little town up
there on that Plateau right you know
waterfall it can be
sustained right but like it's all of it
is just like build up build up build up
like water in the garden hose and you
pinch the end of it and then that and
it's just like more pressure more
pressure until it's just like it's it's
going to blow and like somebody cut the
pressure off it's oh turn somebody cut
the pressure off no it's like they took
the kink out of the hose no I'm saying
for a man it's like for a man yeah like
you take the kink out of the hose and
then somebody cut the water off but
Jenna you were about to say something I
yeah just to clarify with the the
clitoris and sensitivity and enjoyment
it's not necessarily enjoyment it's that
we have more nerve endings there than
like five
five times the nerve endings in the
clitoris than the head of the penis so
like whatever you're doing with the
penis divide that by five that's what
you should be doing with the clitoris
and that's kind of where you start yeah
yeah okay and then the enjoyment yes the
enjoyment is a and orgasm last much
longer for women as well right and you
can have so many more yeah you can like
ride one right into the next one it's
crazy right right right right right I'm
so jealous it's like it's so easy for us
I mean there's a lot more work but
like I actually think it's just this
great Cosmic analogy you know it's like
the way that it works it's like for
someone with a penis it's just like
doesn't take much it's going to be fun
but it's going to be over real quick but
the investment in the in the entire
situation with a vagina and clitoris and
everything that goes along with it but
then the reward is is more is longer and
you can enjoy it for longer so it's kind
of like I don't know it's like
this you know I mean you can be on the
edge you can be on the edge of
ejaculation for you for you know you can
surf that
line and stay just below it and it's
like that's very pleasurable but it's
just but it but there is this sensation
of it being like you know you're on the
verge of an explosion and it's not it's
kind of like running from a thief though
you know running from somebody who's
trying to mug you it's like you it's
it's not that enjoyable it is not the
thing it's not what you in that moment
it's not you're not running what my
impression uh with the only woman that
I've had a sexual experience with is
that she's running toward something very
very hard and and completely unabashedly
for an extremely long period of time
where I'm like I get really close to the
edge I'm like I got to turn around I
want to jump but I got to stay on this
ledge and then you get up to to I got to
run back I got to run back it's I mean
it's fun it's like the differ but she
seems like she's having even more
fun yeah that's that's all I'm saying I
you look at my face and I'm
concentrating right right right what
he's do that guy's doing math right he's
solving problems right
now I mean the eyes will roll back in
the heading the eyes roll back but they
do one rotation then they're back I can
see again you know they don't disappear
for like man I just wish they could
disappear for you know you know 13
minutes a quickie yeah yeah just 13
minutes so there it is our best
description of the male orgasm is that
it's it's just subpar to the female
orgasm in my
opinion but we that we have nothing to
compare it to except our own we have
nothing to compare it
to I mean it's still the greatest
feeling and uh that I've ever felt I
think yeah definitely oh yeah I mean I
can't think of yeah it's not nothing is
I've heard people
say Better Than Sex about a number of
things you know how much I like to eat
man but yeah there's no way I never had
a burger got close to sex and I love to
eat you know no I'm not yeah I I can't I
mean what else would be another
candidate for what else do people say
Better Than Sex well some people who I
mean some people who
and this is not obviously don't do this
but people who have tried heroin and
stuff like that like drugs that are hard
drugs that like send you way over the
top that are highly addictive those
people will get into a place where
they're like this is better than sex
because it's doing something to your
brain that it was definitely not
designed to have happened to it I I
definitely don't want to find that out
so no no plans to try that uh Liam goat
felons asks a technical question does
oral sex count as sex my roommates used
to get into full-blown debates about
this
full-blown
um well Liam according to who I guess is
the question because again this this
question is most often asked in the
context of like a religious argument
it's like how far is too far it's okay
well God in his wisdom has determined
that um okay if you if you touch the
nipple it's you know that's uh that gets
this score in sin and then if you and
then if but you have sex that's that
goes over the over the limit of course I
don't believe that that's how the
universe works so I think that oral sex
counts as oral
sex yeah I think they you know what I'm
saying oral sex is oral what do you mean
count sex it's a different thing count
according to who I guess it's like if
you're saying that like if you've had
oral sex but you haven't had intercourse
are you a are you still a virgin again
the concept of virginity is also based
in this religious framework yeah it's
kind of a [__] concept right
construct it's a construct it's an idea
that a group of people who believe a
certain thing about the world have
agreed upon but is it it doesn't status
is not changed because you have had sex
or not had sex there's not
so um oral sex is a certain thing that
involves the mouth in a sexual organ and
then
intercourse is when the sex the
genitalia are involved yeah
so you know what I'm saying so it's like
I don't I guess I don't understand the
premise of the question is difficult for
me to understand if it's not based in a
particular moral
framework I think it matters most about
what it what it means to the you know
the person you're doing it with and
being on the same page about the like
the all the implications
emotional the only thing I'm sure of is
if you spill your seed God will strike
you down okay what what I I I still
don't you don't remember this I I do
remember the phrase and even the name
laan but I don't remember the story I
don't I don't think it was laan it may
have been laan I got to look this up now
okay so now you're Googling what Bible
spill seed meaning
death Onin Onin but Onin knew this is
Genesis 38 this is the
NIV uh but on knew that the offspring
would not be his so wherever he lay with
his whenever he lay with his brother's
wife he spilled his semen on the ground
he pulled out to keep from producing
offspring ining for his brother what he
did was wicked in the Lord's sight so he
put him to death
also so maybe this is only if you're
having sex with your brother's wife so I
don't know how it
works uh don't have any experience with
that personally so uh may not have been
the SE part at all let me just take it
all
back if you're having SE the only thing
I'm sure of when it comes to this is
that if you're having sex with your
brother's wife and you spill your seed
God will kill you mhm and I would like
sure anything else that a quickie is 13
minutes I just don't know what 13
minutes is or 8 in honestly I don't
really give a [__] um you know what get
I can I can come quick and I can take a
long time and it and it's none of your
business but I sure the hell I've been
talking about
it it's none it's none of your business
but we've been talking about our sex
lives very openly oh so that I think
that brings to a close
setember yeah hey man this has been this
has been it's been a fun one hey man
feel like we've learned a lot uh I will
say that U we didn't bring any experts
in this year you know people who
actually have studied these things um so
again if there's a gap you want us to
fill right let us know hash
earbiscuits or uh leave us a voicemail
with how you're processing all this 1888
earpod one Speaking of people that you
should listen to about things experts I
have a recommendation somebody I
actually discovered this morning morning
I uh I have a huge respect for good
science communicators right I this is
this is something I'm sort of into my
Niche my wife always laughs at me as I
like to watch things that are technical
while I work
out um but I found uh debunk the funk
with Dr Wilson YouTube channel Dr Dan
Wilson I think is his name he is a
molecular biologist who um basically he
took it upon himself in 2020 to begin
addressing all the misinformation uh
related to the pandemic and I just love
the way that he communicates and I know
in many ways we feel like we're kind of
past the we're definitely past the
darkest days of the pandemic but it's
funny
how I don't think we've yet recovered
from what happened to us in the way that
uh people consume information and what
we can agree on and boy howdy when the
next pandemic comes we're going to be in
for it because this one didn't go well
um but it's great having a voice like
his that if you hear something on really
popular podcasts for
instance the funk about vaccines or coid
or whatever oh what what podcast could
that yeah I don't know what podcast I'm
talking about uh you you might be led to
believe certain things about these
matters that are not based in fact and I
think that he does a really really good
job of breaking it down in very simple
terms and communicating in a way that
anyone can understand but pointing to
resources that uh he and other people
like him have actually studied so debunk
the funk with Dr Wilson great Science
Channel on YouTube check him
out okay talk to him next week oh and
also want to remind you uh that my first
single off of this phase of my music
James and the shame of the EP that's
coming in November dropped on Friday
it's called Nothing Left to love which
is also just a title track I'm starting
with the title track because why not why
not uh so check it out wherever you
stream your music hey guys um I'm a
25-year-old woman I live in a large
apartment complex in New York City um
and I sometimes feel compromised
especially when I'm listening to
sextember because um the walls are thin
here and I'm just just putting myself in
the position of one of my neighbors um
and imagining what they're thinking when
they get a little blip of what's going
on in ear
biscuits and honestly I'm not mad about
it love you guys so much um thanks for
everything you do to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
ear biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the cirular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best